[Applause]
thank you Barbara for that introduction
um and for your great service to this
great Union and thank you Congress for
that very warm welcome uh it's a
pleasure it's always a pleasure to be in
Brighton in the sunshine and especially
when the sun is beginning to shine on
Labor's arguments
now there's more work to be done
of course there is and I'm under No
Illusion
the hardest yards are ahead of us
we need to be prepared
disciplined relentlessly focused on the
future
show we're ready to provide the
leadership that this country so
desperately needs meet Tory attacks with
hope
but make no mistake
if we keep demonstrating
that we're a changed labor party
but in everything we do we put country
first
that we know what true service means
then together we have a golden
opportunity to shape the future to the
interests of working people firmly and
decisively
all around us
the world is changing
it's becoming a more volatile place
Revolutions in Technology Energy and
Medicine are reshaping the economy and
our Public Services
climate change is driving Global
instability
War has returned to our continent
our job is to lead working people
through these headwinds
provide the confidence that Britain will
be better for their children
bend the future
so it delivers the stability the dignity
and the hope that they need
Congress a tide has turned
the rest of the world is moving on from
the outdated ideas our opponents provide
the economic argument which has held
back working people is now on the back
foot
put simply people aren't going to take
it anymore
they've had enough
you know that
when you ask the key questions now
where does growth come from
who's it for
the Tory answers they just don't wash
when it's your interests on the line
your service is being cut your bills and
taxes going up the tourists say well
we're all in this together
but when it comes to protecting their
interests it's
well this is just the way of the world
what people are seeing through that
13 years of the Tories and it boils down
to this
one rule for them another for working
people
[Applause]
and Congress
why is the next election the prizes is
not just to win
not just to change our country but to
put this damaging idea in the ground for
good
that's what my labor party this project
has always been about
I've always said
we have different roles different ways
of fighting for working people
party and movement
I was there in 1986 in whopping when the
police charged the picket
doing my job as a legal Observer
everyone who stood in solidarity with
the print workers
they were doing their job as well
but you know I I remember thinking that
night
there's one Institution
that isn't doing its job here
the labor party
no because the labor party was in
opposition
it was on the sidelines it was impotent
and Powerless
that's the condition of opposition and I
can't stand it and Gary I know you share
that frustration
because just look at the price working
people pay for it
the stagnation the economic pain the
cuts to Public Services attacks on
working people and this movement
in Parliament again this week a bill
that takes away your hard-earned
Democratic rights
now I can stand here and say
we will fight it
and we'll repeal it
about my words we will
but
this only demonstrates the prize of
power
the labor party is never doing its job
when it's in opposition that's our
Clause one
but power must always have a purpose
and I accept that the labor party did
drift away from its fundamental cause of
serving working people
so I want to be clear
everything I do
all the changes we're making are in the
service of this goal they are grounded
in a new project which understands
that the labor party can only restore
hope in Britain
if we once again become the natural home
for working people
this is in our DNA
who we're in it for who we serve but we
wake up in the morning and fight for who
we have in our Mind's Eye when we make
decisions who we back to grow our
economy
the answer the only answer
the labor answer is working people
and friends my government will work
every day to serve their interests and
protect their future
this is
about respect and dignity
and for me it goes deep
my dad was a working man a tool maker
who worked all his life in a factory
he was thought but people looked down on
him for that and it weighed him down it
chipped away at his esteem
and there are millions of people in this
country today who feel just like my dad
did
and that's not good enough
I want Britain to be a country where
people don't have to change who they are
just to get on
and at the very least
a bare minimum whoever you are whatever
your circumstances however you
contribute
whether you work for Asda Amazon or the
ambulance service you deserve respect
and that's not just a moral imperative
it's also a vast spring of potential
ready to be tapped
because when people are respected when
they feel their contribution carries
weight when they're able to bring their
whole self to their work
that they're treated fairly and with
dignity
then their shoulders lift up their
belief comes back
hope and pride are restored
and when I tell you exactly what my
labor party will do for working people
in the pros of policy and rights
I never lose sight of the emotions the
values the ordinary hopes that sit
behind them
the dignity and esteem which comes with
respect in the workplace
that's our project
it's a project for carers the couriers
the ambulance drivers the supermarket
staff
those in the office and those on the
factory floor
those working long shifts night shifts
nine to fives
those working part-time and those
working full-time
my labor party is the party for those
who keep us safe who create the wealth
who make up the backbone of Britain this
is a project for working people all
across our country
foreign
those are the people the country clapped
for during the pandemic
even the residents of Downing Street
found time to stumble into the street to
do it
take careers as an example
because there's a subject very close to
my heart
for many of them every time they had to
self-isolate during the crisis
they did So at their own expense with no
sick pay
that's not a home but let me be very
clear those days are coming to an end
a country that doesn't respect care work
is an uncaring country
so we will strike a fair pay agreement
for every care worker in the country
we'll we'll get you around the table and
the deal you make will set a new floor a
higher floor with more progression more
training more rights better standards
and yes fairer pay a fair pay deal for
our parents
that's what people clapped for and
that's what labor will deliver
but this this goes to the heart of the
tourist failure
it's why we've had 13 years of chaos
that's left our economy broken
they simply don't get that growth comes
from working people
and because they don't understand that
fundamental
they can't provide the secure
foundations to build our country's
future
to be honest I'm not even sure they see
the problem
if the city of London races ahead whilst
the rest of Britain stagnates
as long as there's a hint of growth on
this spreadsheet which he soon act will
claim that that's fine
but it's not
if you leave that many people behind a
nation can't grow fairly you can't do it
with low wages you can't do it with
insecure jobs and bad work with a
standard side government that doesn't
fight for the future
without a proper industrial strategy
the average British family
is eight thousand eight hundred pounds
poorer than in other advanced economies
an economies like France
Germany and the Netherlands
economies that have better collective
bargaining have stronger workers rights
and a fairer share of wealth across
their country
so we will strengthen the role of trade
unions and our society
and like you I want to see Amazon and
businesses like it recognize trade
unions
[Applause]
nobody does their best work if they're
wrapped with fear about the future if
their insecure contract gives them no
protection to stand up for their rights
at work
or a proper safety net that doesn't
support them properly
that's what Labor's New Deal for working
people is about
that's why we'll ban Zero Hour contracts
extend parental leave strengthen
flexible working better protection for
pregnant women close the ethnicity pay
Gap fundamental rights from day one
statutory sick pay for all no more
one-sided flexibility and no more fire
and rehire foreign
[Applause]
people have been told that good pay Fair
work and dignity are somehow barriers to
growth well no more a reformed labor
market where we finally make work pay
provide the security denied to working
people for decades that's my mission on
growth
but you know
we're not a nation apart
the world around us is changing
and changing fast
President Biden once said
when I hear climate change I think jobs
when labor sets out our mission for
Britain to become a clean energy
superpower we are thinking jobs too
for too long
Britain has allowed the opportunities of
the new Energy Technologies to pass Us
by
without a plan the energy industries
that we rely on will wither and decline
now the tourists think it's the market
doing its job when British industry
falls behind it's not some glitch in
their model it is their model
yet our allies around the Democratic
world are waking up to the threat of
energy insecurity and the opportunity of
Economic Security
change is coming
and yes it can unsettle us
but mark my words
on my watch good jobs good union jobs
will be fundamental to that change
decent pay respect dignity and fairness
cleaner safer work new and better
infrastructure for Britain these are the
purposes of our party and they are
historic prizes we will win again
I won't pretend that just because a
technology is greener that automatically
makes working conditions fairer
so as new nuclear battery factories and
offshore wind repower Britain Britain
will supply strong chains that create
jobs skills and decent wages here in
Britain
work with you work with you to seize the
opportunities of hydrogen carbon capture
and Storage
our green Prosperity plan like President
Biden's inflation reduction Act is our
plan for growth
and because we're labor it is a plan for
working people their jobs and their
prosperity
we will create a new company
GB energy
and through that vehicle we will take
advantage of the opportunities that we
have
and because it's right for jobs because
it's right for growth because it's right
for energy Independence then yes it will
be publicly owned
GB energy will be good for Britain and
good for business
it will have twin goals
leading the way in better jobs and lower
bills
and I'm clear-eyed about how tough the
challenges that faced us are
we have all seen what happens when
politicians see change as something to
stand and stare at in awe When
government surrenders working people to
the power of the market
when the future comes and people are
left behind
that is why the next election is so
important for the future of working
people
holding back the future is no way to
growth
but equally there is no way to growth
that doesn't involve bending and shaping
that future
we can create a new business model for
Britain one which creates Economic
Security and grows not just our
productivity
but our hope and our optimism
labor in government will work with
unions and with industry we will always
have a stake we will always have skin in
the game we will always see the fight
for working people as our driving
purpose
because for us
this is personal
together we will make Britain work
better
together we will give working people
their future back together we will build
a better Britain thank you Congress
thank you
thank you thank you Congress
thank you Congress
thank you
I think and hope that we're now going to
have some questions from members of the
audience members of GMB
um and if I've got this right they're
going to come up so that everybody can
hear the questions
and I think the first question is Mary
I'm sorry Mary
good morning
for working people a campaign mandate to
win the next general election yeah
can you give us a firm commitment that
the labor party will fully support the
New Deal and be bold and campaigning for
a fairer and more equal country for
millions of families and working people
yes
[Applause]
the friends and colleagues
um
as we've been in opposition we've
developed actually very few bits of
legislation that are ready to hit the
ground on day one but our new deal for
working people is one of those bits of
legislation in fact it was the first bit
of legislation that we drafted
um and I'm very proud that it was agreed
with the trade unions we worked on this
together many people in this room
contributed to the New Deal for working
people it was announced as you know by
Angela Rayner back in 2021 at our
conference I've obviously mentioned it
in my speech now Mary because just
selling out some of the issues that are
in it and we've made a commitment that
this will be legislation in the first
hundred days of a labor government so
it's a big yes it's a it's it's a
prepared piece of work it's a joint
piece of work and we've got a timetable
for implementing it it is the final
thing I'd say is as and I said this when
we launched the document this is why
winning an election is so important
because that piece of draft legislation
has two futures
if we don't win the election
it'll gather dust on a Shelf
and you'll have other legislation
brought in by the respiratory government
that does even more damage to your
rights that's one route the other route
is we go forward we're in that election
and we implement it within the first
hundred days together with you that's
the future I want for our country thank
you Mary
hi here my name is Sarah and I'm from
the Wales and southwest region so you
just said that care work is really close
to your heart so Kenny where does the
pay just a few pennies above minimum
wage on average the average hourly wage
was 10 pound and three Pence last year
labor has said it would look at
implementing a fair payment which you
just mentioned in the social care would
set an hourly minimum but you said but
you've not said what that minimum should
be can I ask you as past leader what you
think it should be Sarah can I first
make it clear that
um I deeply respect the work of care
workers not least because as you may
know my sister's a care worker and there
I know week by week month by month year
by year just how hard it is
working in the care sector and we are
absolutely determined to change this and
to change it comprehensively and that's
why the fair pay agreement is so
important and our commitment is to is to
the first payer group first Fair program
I want to be for carers I want that to
be the lead case if you like and that
will be negotiated by you because this
is a fair play agreement which involves
the unions agreeing
um across the country so I don't want
different care providers picking off
groups of workers wherever they are I
want one structure one agreement across
the country and that is intended as I
set out in the speech to set a flaw a
higher floor for every single care
worker and that will involve terms and
conditions dignity respect I think I'm
writing saying Sarah you'll know this
better than me but one in three people
who leave the care sector do so to join
the NHS and they do that because they
feel there's better progression in the
NHS and so we have to deal with
progression training respect but it also
has to deal with pay and it has to be
higher payers I've set out now as to the
rate of pay you will be negotiating that
around the table and once and you will
know what you think is right in
whichever year it is 2024 maybe 2025
that we're able to get this agreement
over the line you will negotiate that
rate you will know what's right for your
members and once that's done the
agreement will then be binding for all
care workers including those who aren't
able to negotiate a better rate for
themselves so that's how I see it
working Sarah thank thank you for
everything you do but this is going to
be an important part of what I hope
we'll be able to do in the very early
years of the next Labor government thank
you Sarah
[Applause]
and I think we've got Dave possibly
and I'm also speaking for all the
workers in the gas industry and there's
a lot of talk and just about just
transitioning the energy sector but
right now it's just that talk UK has
lost on and continue to lose out on high
quality unionized manufacturing
Renewables jobs where you give serious
support to workers like me in the energy
sector and our families by calling on
calling for a moratorium on future
offshore wind projects until the UK has
secured the unshowing of jobs in this
sector so that we can have proper jobs
transition but Dave look
[Applause]
the heart of your questions are really
important issue which is jobs in here in
the UK and I think many people in this
Union working people across the country
have been badly let down and we've got
to do more about it Dave now I don't
actually think a moratorium is Way
Forward but I do think that we've got to
use Vehicles like GB energy that will be
a publicly owned vehicle where we
determine where the jobs are to ensure
that they are here in the UK and that we
have incentives in contracts to look at
Supply chains and where the jobs are for
the supply chain so Dave let me just
um give you an example that shows
um I absolutely understand where you're
coming from I was at Hinkley Point C
yesterday
um amongst other things meeting the GMB
reps there
um and and that's a you know a fantastic
project about the future of nuclear in
this country it's way behind schedule
because the government's been dithering
and delaying but as Gary Smith pointed
out to me this morning
in the supply chain to Hinckley point
the only thing that's made in Britain is
the concrete
everything else comes from abroad that's
got to be wrong
and you talk about Renewables Dave in
whiteley's which as you know is the
onshore wind farm just outside Glasgow I
think the biggest one in the UK I went
there
to see for myself how it worked to
understand the challenges and when I
asked how many of these I think it's 350
wind turbines were built in Britain the
answer was none of them
they came from Indonesia because we'd
lost the race to get those jobs so Dave
at the heart of your question is
something I believe in very strongly
which is the next generation of jobs the
jobs that we need to secure and hold on
to then jobs of the future we have to
find a way of making sure that they're
here in the UK and I want the main jobs
the project jobs in Renewables and other
sectors to be here in the UK and I want
the supply chain jobs to be here in the
UK as well thank you very much Dave a
really really important point
[Applause]
I think I've got Jason
foreign
Irish Kia labor has said when it's in
power it will bring back the two-tier
chord that would mean outsourced workers
appeared the same as those in-house
you've also said that you would bring
about the biggest wave of insourcing in
a generation can you tell us what
contracts you'd prioritize bringing back
yeah Jason look thank you for raising
that important issue this is obviously
as you know not a new issue this one has
been in with us for a very very long
time that's why
um the two-tier code was introduced by
the last Labor government
but then uh shamelessly it was scrapped
by the coalition government as soon as
they got the first opportunity to do so
so we've got to reinstate it we've got
to get it back and what Angela Rayner is
working on with the GMB I'm glad to say
is how we not just bring it back but how
we strengthen it and that's the key
issue those discussions are going on
with your colleagues but Rachel Reeves
you mentioned this Dave uh Jason set the
um the direction of travel really
because she talked about the biggest
wave of insourcing and that for me is
the most important thing to make sure
that we get the skills the respect the
pay the terms and conditions exactly
where they should be so on that code we
need to reinstate it please keep working
with Angela on how we strengthen that
and I look forward to working with you
on it as well thank you very much Jason
I've got I think to our field
Garfield
Heights
[Applause]
would like to take this opportunity to
convey this to you please Amazon is one
of the world's worthiest wealthiest
corporations offering the workers in the
UK a pay rise in pennant despite this
Amazon is a beneficiary of payments
payouts from the public purse receiving
684 million in Central and local
government contracts since 2018.
Amazon is a responsible employer driving
down paying conditions refusing to
recognize its workers this makes a
conservative government happy with this
state of affairs our question to you at
GMB Amazon what will your labor
government do to stop this flow of
public money to Amazon if they continue
to refuse recognition other workers
union yeah
[Applause]
foreign
and and can I just start by
acknowledging the campaign that GMB is
running on this a fantastic campaign a
really important campaign and one that I
fully support and I want to see Amazon
recognize trade unions and it's really
important to say that and I'm clear
about that and I just want to say to
this audience I've come here and I've
said that in my speech today
but I also say it in my speeches to the
CBI and to the British Chamber of
Commerce because
I come here and talk about the
importance of business and how we need
to partner with business and I talk to
business about how we need to partner
and work with trade unions so that's
fundamentally important and if I just
came here and said it and didn't say it
there you wouldn't believe I meant it so
I'm absolutely giving that assurance and
in terms of how we bring this about I
think public procurement I think the
point you make about contracts is really
important it's not a free-for-all
there's a lot of public money tied up in
public procurement and an incoming labor
government is entitled to say it comes
with terms and petitions
there's a framework for public
procurement at the heart of which is
dignity and respect and we expect to see
unionized jobs and support unionized
businesses so Garfield I think if we
continue to work together on this your
campaign must go on but you know it
gives us that chance it's another
example and I will keep coming back to
this but it could be my central Focus
um you know we've been in opposition for
13 years Garfield 13 years if we win the
election this is why I'm so
single-mindedly focused on it and all
the noise is up about everything else
we've got to win that election because
we get the chance then to bring about
the change that you and others are
campaigning for so thank you for what
you're doing thank you for what you'll
continue to do and I'll work with you
for it and if we get a labor government
and I hope that we will then we can be
in a position to do something about this
thank you Garfield very very much
[Applause]
I have a time I think
thank you GMB Scotland
oil and gas are fundamental foundations
of the Scottish economy which she owns
from krakodi to Cambridge Labor's
position on blocking new licenses is a
threat to Scottish jobs and the UK
energy security
without glue licenses we'll be relying
on imports from other countries who will
reap the benefits of the jobs and taxes
the SNP of repeatedly promised a green
job Revolution are far from being on
Oasis of what Scotland has become the
desert desert we need oil and gas jobs
so when the current fuels in the North
Sea are depleted in Scotland's oil and
gas jobs evaporate what would you tell
or not our members work in any sectors
in the communities which will be
decimated yeah Sam look thank you so
much
thank you for raising that thank you for
raising that and I absolutely share your
concern about future jobs I absolutely
share that concern and I do know that
you and others and working people across
the country have been let down by the
Tories and let down by the SMP on this
promises about jobs that never
materialize and I want to be absolutely
clear oil and gas are going to be part
of the mix for decades to come into the
2050s and I don't think that part of our
argument is heard loud enough and
clearly enough for decades to come oil
and gas will be part of the mix but at
the heart of your question Tam is this
crucial issue
what happens next
what happens next and what I will never
let happen
is a repeat of what happened in coal
mining
where an industry came to an end and
nobody had planned for the future and
we're still living with the consequences
we cannot allow that to happen and I
think there is an opportunity now
to seize the next generation of jobs
in nuclear in new nuclear in Renewables
across the country and there's a race on
it's going on around look at the
inflation reduction act in America look
at the eu's response there's a race on
for the next generation of jobs and we
need to be in that race
the wind turbines in white leaves were
not built in Britain because we didn't
get ahead of the game we cannot let that
happen again so we're going to seize
that opportunity to get those jobs in
Renewables and I have estimated there's
hundreds of thousands of jobs to be had
future jobs 50 000 in Scotland 50 000
jobs in Scotland and we can use the
skills that we've got we can deploy
those skills and we can make sure
through GB energy through procurement
that those jobs are in the places that
need them because we don't want to
repeat the error of saying you've got to
move you've got to go we don't need to
come to you to your community you can we
can let you wither we will never repeat
that but if we don't seize that
opportunity
if we just sit back and wait without
acting now on our green Prosperity plan
then I genuinely think Congress that
future Generations will never forgive us
for repeating the mistake was made when
the coal mines were closed down so Tam
will work with you on that thank you for
raising it it's such an important issue
thank you Tam
and I think I've got Joshua left Joshua
hi um I'm Joshua from Southern Region
and I'm a
just down the road and they've recently
announced that they're cutting the pay
of 7 000 colleagues across south east of
England this amounts to 60p an hour pay
cut for a group of workers who has kept
us fed throughout the pandemic not only
are us to threatening to cut pay but
anybody who doesn't accept or facing a
various practice of fire and rehire yeah
as you know we are the union of British
gas workers so we have seen this
disgrace before what is your message to
Asda well Joshua firstly again let me
acknowledge the GMP campaign on this
really important campaign
seriously important campaign
and with it the campaign in relation to
British gas as well which GMB LED from
the front
um and the answer your question is very
very clear so far as I'm concerned we
will ban firing rehire it's as simple as
that it just needs to be done
and and I'll just elaborate that on
Joshua and I'll and you know if there's
one thing that comes through everything
I've said here this will be a repeat of
it I'm afraid we've pushed the
government we've pushed amendments we've
voted against the government on this
we've urged them to bring this in they
say it's the wrong thing but they don't
do anything about it and so we're going
to be stuck with it unless until we win
an election if we win that election
we will ban it and that's my frustration
with opposition I can stand there in
Parliament on the opposition benches
saying fire and rehire is wrong we can
vote against it but we're not changing
it on your behalf and on behalf of
working people across the country we
will only change it because this
government's not going to budge on it
they know what they're doing they're not
going to suddenly have to turn of heart
so we have to go on make the argument
win the election work with you and ban
it and that's what we will do thank you
so much Joshua and thank you Congress
thank you for having me thank you for
inviting me thank you so much